upper Moon 4 huntengu is the trickiest
demon in the series with an incredibly
dangerous blood demon art it comes into
effect when someone cuts off the head of
the demon form that huntegu normally
uses the head and the body will then
each transform into two separate clones
and if those two clones are relieved of
their heads they will just multiply
again to turn into four clones these
four clones can also combine into a
fifth clone that is way stronger than
all the previous ones and then there's a
sixth clone that looks like Han tengu's
real body but is actually yet another
trick you can't really kill these clones
you have to find huntegu's main body and
kill it but the demon can hide his
presence and make his main body really
small so it's harder to find for more
information on Han Tengu including his
backstory and all seven demon forms
check out my full video link in the
description and in the pinned comment